Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan. Wir stehen wieder vor dem Salon.
Wir sitzen, ja.
Wir sitzen, ganz richtig. Da frage ich dich, hast du denn schon die Haftbefehl-Doku geguckt?
Hab ich nicht. Ich habe ja einen echten Musikgeschmack. Also ich lass mir das ja nicht von Juan Moreno erklären, was jetzt cool ist. Deswegen war ich am Wochenende bei André Rieu.
Ja.
Und gestern bei Nina Chuba. Und das ist im Grunde die Erzählung.
Ja, aber irgendwo dazwischen ist ja vielleicht auch Platz für Haftbefehl. Ich erinnere mich, und du wirst dich vielleicht auch erinnern, an die Föjeton Jahre 2014, 15, 16, als es im Föjeton absolut dazugehörte, dass man große Texte, Elogen auf Haftbefehl schrieb. Zum Beispiel auch in deiner FAZ.
Okay.
Ja, ja.
So war das damals. Ich weiß nicht, wer Haftbefehl ist. Ich weiß, er hat ein Lied, das heißt 069. Ich wohne hier in 069. Könnte aber auch Offenbach sein. Also soweit ist schon. Er ist dann auf dem Bach aufgewachsen. Okay. Für mich ist das alles so weit weg wie Eintracht Frankfurt. Also es gibt anscheinend zwei große Sachen, die, also ich weiß nicht mal, wie der aussieht. Ich weiß gar nichts. Aber ich möchte euch den Podcast Brennpunkt empfehlen. Da wird darüber geredet, wie man das auch sehen kann, dass irgendwelche Hamburg-Mitte-Journalisten, die sich ja mal verdient gemacht haben, mit denen sie oder Lothius aber jetzt selber ins Märchen-Business abgedriftet sind und uns einfach so ein migrantisches Schicksal zum Fraß vorwerfen, bei dem möglichst ausgeblendet wird. Das ist ja ein Netflix-Doku von etablierten deutschen Institutionen. Alle schauen die und reden dann nur über Haftbefehl. Also auch immer wieder wunderbar, wie man so ein Apparat einfach ausblenden kann.
Naja, aber das ist ja sowieso eigentlich die Struktur dieser Hip-Hop-Erfolge. Denn Haftbefehl hat ja tatsächlich interessante Texte, wenn ich das so oberflächlich betrachtet sagen darf. Ich habe mich ja auch mit der Musik nicht tiefer beschäftigt. Ich glaube allerdings, dass sein Werk sehr viel interessanter ist als diese Doku, die ich ja auch analysiert habe. Mir ist aber doch erst einmal wichtig zu sagen, dass wir grundsätzlich diese Konstellation haben, wenn da jemand mit einer großen Street-Credibility kommt, dann muss er, um erfolgreich zu sein, selbstredend mit den großen Konzernen kooperieren. Das hat er ja auch getan musikalisch mit Universal, die auch dort zu Wort kommen und sehr gut wegkommen. Es wird ja eigentlich so getan, als gäbe es nur dieses Trauma im Hintergrund, das dazu geführt hat, dass jetzt Haftbefehl diesen Niedergang erlebt, dass er sich selbst ruiniert. Aber man sieht gar nicht so dieses systemische Gefüge dahinter. Jedenfalls ist es ja generell dann so, dass dort, wo es rein um den Kommerz geht, man sich natürlich auf den einen oder anderen Pakt mit dem Teufel einlässt. Das ist ja etwas, was zu dieser Popkultur absolut dazugehört. Also es ist nicht so, dass wir da einen Klassenkämpfer haben, der nichts anderes getan hat, als zu versuchen, seine Botschaft zu ventilieren, sondern es ging ja auch immer darum, einen Eistee zu verkaufen.
Ich finde es nur immer wieder interessant und deswegen werde ich mir das auch nie angucken, weil ich mich ja nicht zu diesen Opfern zähle, die das zu Hause gucken, wie vor 20 Jahren Roundhouse bei RTL 2, wie man es als Netflix-Apparat oder grundsätzlich Medien-Apparat schafft, vorzugaukeln. Wir machen hier gerade eine Zäsur, gehen in die Metaebene und schweben über dem Phänomen.
Ja, das geht gar nicht.
Obwohl die Netflix-Doku selbst natürlich der größte biografische Einschnitt überhaupt in Haftbefehl zu leben ist.
Ja.
Denn erstmals hat er diese Grenzen überwunden und es ist nicht nur 069 und Hip-Hop, sondern jetzt ist ganz Deutschland. Und jeder fragt mich, hast du schon die Haftbefehl-Doku gesehen? Und ich frage einfach immer nur zurück, heißt die wirklich Haftbefehl-Doku oder hat die auch einen eigenen Namen?
Nein, die heißt Babo, die Haftbefehl-Story.
Siehste, das habe ich noch nie gehört.
Über alle Haftbefehl-Doku, Haftbefehl-Doku. Story sollte man auf jeden Fall da nochmal als solches betrachten. Du hast es ja schon gesagt. Juan Moreno ist der Spiegeljournalist, der damals Relotius aufgedeckt hat, wie Relotius am Schreibtisch saß und sich Geschichten ausgedacht hat, so wie man sie gerne lesen würde. Nun ist es hier bei der Doku so, dass ja tatsächlich Haftbefehl, also Aykut Anhan möchte, dass diese Geschichte über ihn erzählt wird. Seine Brüder kommen vor, seine Frau und viele weitere Wegbereiter. Aber das Interessante ist jetzt nur noch mal, dass Haftbefehl sagt, er will, dass die Wahrheit erzählt wird und sagt dann aus seiner Sicht. Und damit ist ja schon gleich etwas gesetzt, nämlich dass seine Sicht vielleicht nicht die ganze Wahrheit sein kann, denn es ist dann nur seine Sicht. Zugleich ist es aber auch nicht nur seine Sicht, weil laufend irgendwelche Wegbegleiter zu Wort kommen, andere Kollegen, wer auch immer. Das heißt, wir erleben, dass dort ja eine Story produziert wird, die dann doch nicht einfach nur Haftbefehl Story ist, sondern eine, die die beiden Regisseure sich ausgedacht haben und die natürlich vor allem den Story-Anforderungen von Netflix folgen muss. Und das bedeutet schnelle Schlitte, noch ein dramatischer Punkt, noch ein dramatischer Punkt, Steigerung, Steigerung, Steigerung. Und dann, wir werden sehen, wie es mit Haftbefehl weitergeht. Ich weiß, wie es weitergeht. Das heißt also, diese Dramaturgie, die dort gespielt wird, ist ja nicht einfach die Wahrheit, das Leben, sondern genau das ist die Konstruktion, die Netflix einfordert, damit eine solche Doku gedreht werden kann. Es ist ein bisschen so, es gibt ja die große Komponisten-Witwe, Alma Maler-Werfel, die hat eine Autobiografie geschrieben und am Ende schreibt sie, und nun liegt mein ganzes Leben vor mir wie ein Roman. Ja, du hast dir den Roman deines Lebens geschrieben. Und genau dieses Fiktionale der Dokumentation muss man, glaube ich, erkennen. Deshalb ist das schon eine schöne Pointe, dass jetzt Juan Moreno, der die ganze Zeit darauf beharrte, nein, Relotio, so geht es nicht, sagen, was ist, jetzt auch eine fiktionale Konstruktion uns liefert, was nicht bedeutet, dass da Dinge vorkommen, die nicht stimmen, sondern er blendet ganz viel aus, um genau diese Netflix-Logik, die ja offenbar gut funktioniert, entsprechend produzieren und abliefern zu können.
Das können wir doch von diesen Spiegelleuten, die gibt es dann immer doppelt. Die sind ja dann bei Netflix oder Feldenkirchen macht auf der einen Seite das große Politikerbuch, das ist natürlich alles echt, was da drin steht. Genauso ist der Wahlkampf abgelaufen von Martin Schulz, als er beraterresistent, hätte doch man vorher wissen können, im Nachhinein sind wir alle schlauer. Aber dann, Podcastspaß macht man einfach nicht beim Spiegel, sondern geht man dann zu Mickey Beisenherz. Ich finde es jedenfalls sehr gut, dass ich jetzt auch über Sachen so nachdenke, wie zum Beispiel, ich bekomme eine E-Mail in diesen Tagen, Barbos coming home, World Club Dome nächstes Jahr natürlich, mit Haftbefehl als Headliner.
Wirklich?
Und jetzt habe ich überlegt, kaufe ich mir jetzt ein Ticket oder gehe ich jetzt zu Polymarkets, um darauf zu wetten, ob er da noch lebt oder nicht?
Ja, das ist ja das zynische Spiel. Und darum geht es ja die ganze Zeit. Also ist dieses zynische Spiel, kann er noch auftreten, denn wird er noch auftreten und ich würde auch sagen, ist seine Nase noch da? Ja, ganz richtig.
Was ist mit seiner Mutter? Kriegen wir noch eine Doku über die Mutter? Ich habe gehört, die kamen da gar nicht vor.
Nein, die kamen da nicht vor.
Selbst ich bin im Pörder, wo ich gar nicht zugeschaut habe, dass die Mutter nicht vorkam.
So, und genau das ist die Logik, die wir dort sehen. Es geht nicht um die Musik und das ist ja das Dramatische. Und das ist aber auch so typisch für unsere generellen kulturellen Berichterstattungen, dass immer mehr die Musik verdrängt wird.
Kultur meinst du alles, Sport, Politik?
Nein, ich meine Musik, Literatur, Film, etc.
Das ist eigentlich was ausgespart immer.
Wir reden nicht über das Werk, sondern wir reden die ganze Zeit über den Autor. Und wenn der Autor dann Schicksalsschläge hat, dann bitte mehr davon. Wir kennen das von Deutschland sucht den Superstar. Von Anfang an war es da so, dass wenn irgendjemand eine dramatische Geschichte hatte, dann wurde sie ausgeschlachtet ohne Ende und danach wurde das Lied gesungen. Das heißt, das Publikum wird nicht über das Lied, das gesungen wird, emotionalisiert, was ja in Ordnung wäre, sondern erst einmal muss man erfahren, ist aufgewachsen ohne und konnte und weiter und dann hört man das Lied. Das heißt, diese Dramaturgie, die wirklich Boulevard ist, nichts anderes, die finden wir jetzt in der Haftbefehl-Doku genauso wieder, aber die bestimmt auch schon sehr lange unsere kulturellen Berichterstattungen.
Das sind die Prinzipien, die es treiben. Die Akustik in der Festhalle ist so schlecht, weil André Rieu da mit seinem Ensemble kommt, muss natürlich so eine Geschichte her. Also ist die Solistin hat natürlich einen gelähmten Magen und der Panflöden-Spieler hat keine Hände und darüber werden dann die Tränen gerührt. Ein Punkt will ich noch machen. Ich finde es sehr witzig, dass Leute überhaupt nicht durchschauen, dass sie in eine Doku gucken, in der es die ganze Zeit darum geht, dass sich jemand so verhält, wie man es gar nicht versteht. Und wie auch alle, ohne dass man es nochmal sagen muss, denken sollen, also das, was der gerade macht, ist ganz falsch. Der hat sich doch gerade erst ein Gramm Kokain ins linke Nasenloch und jetzt ins rechte, na er ist selber schuld. Aber wenn derselbe Typ, dem man die ganze Zeit nur zusieht, wie er falsche Entscheidungen trifft, nicht mal seinen Urlaub kriegt er geregelt und so, er fühlt sich in seinem Haus nicht wohl, was ist da los? Aber er hat doch am Anfang gesagt, er möchte, dass dieser Film entsteht. Da muss man dann auch mal sagen, nein. Entweder ist der Typ unzurechnungsfähig und muss gerettet werden. Und das geht dann nicht mit Kamera in der Hand, sondern da muss man dann nach 20 Versuchen, das mit Ärzten und Therapeuten zu machen, eben einen 21. Versuch wagen. So ist es halt im wahren Leben. Dann kann man nicht einfach sagen, nee, er hat jetzt von uns 25 Chancen gekriegt mit Therapeuten, jetzt Feuerfreie Kameramann. Das ist einfach absurd.
Das ist auch die Verantwortungslosigkeit, denn wenn man sieht, wie dramatisch die Lage da ist, dann dürfte man eigentlich nicht mit der Kamera ankommen. Dann sagt man ja, aber der wollte das so und der greift ja auch noch selbst nach der Kamera und sagt, ich breche die Doku ab, wenn ihr nicht weiter dreht. Damit hat man sich so einen Freifahrtschein gegeben für alles Mögliche. Aber ich will jetzt eine Parallele ziehen, die vielleicht überraschend sein wird, aber ich glaube, sie ist trifftig. Nadl, Nadja Abdel Farrak, die Ex-Freundin von Dieter Bohlen und die dann durch alle möglichen Reality-Formate getingelt ist, hatte ja seit vielen, vielen Jahren ein sehr starkes Alkoholproblem. Sie ist immer wieder auf Partys, irgendwo auf der Straße, öffentlich auch zusammengebrochen und die Dramaturgie sei immer wie folgt aus, sie ruft dann RTL oder Sat1 an oder die Bildzeitung, dann kommen die wieder, Nadl geht es wieder besser, Nadl geht es schlechter, Nadl möchte zurück in ein normales Leben, Nadl singt jetzt auf Mallorca. Also es waren immer diese Auf und Abs und dann wurde das laufend so weitergetragen, bis irgendwann die Leute sich nicht mehr dafür interessiert haben, dann ist sie einsam in einer winzigen Wohnung in Hamburg gestorben an Leberzerose. Im Prinzip ist diese Dramaturgie eine, die wir jetzt hier in der Doku wiedersehen können, nur ist Haftbefehl finanziell hundertmal besser ausgestattet als Nadl, die dann versuchen musste, irgendwo nochmal 5000 Euro zu verdienen, wenn sie als DJ auftritt. Das ist jetzt hier bei Haftbefehl nicht nötig, aber genau dieser Voyeurismus, den finden wir jetzt dort wieder, und deswegen interessieren sich ja jetzt plötzlich so viele Leute dafür, die nie vorher ein Lied von Haftbefehl gehört haben.
Und deswegen, lieber Herr Moreno, Lebenswerk eingerissen, würde ich sagen. Damals diese Relotius-Aufdeckungsgeschichte, Gold wert und jetzt einfach so ein Scheiß. Ich verstehe das gar nicht, aber gut.
Wir wollen Termine ankündigen. Lass mich erst sagen, wo ich so bin. Ich bin diesen Monat in München, Frankfurt.
In München. Ich will auch noch München.
Innsbruck, Fürth und in Düsseldorf im Filmmuseum spreche ich über die Dokumentation Marlene von Maximilian Schell. Diese fünf Termine findet man auf meiner Homepage wolfgangmschmitt.de. Da gibt es dann auch alle dazugehörigen Links. Dort findet man auch, aber auch in der Beschreibung dann, den gemeinsamen Termin von uns. Wir machen nämlich einen Live-Podcast, Schwerpunkt KI, am 29.11. in Düsseldorf. Abends ist das und es gibt Tickets dafür, die kann man dann, ich glaube, über das Filmmuseum kaufen. Man wird im Link alles finden.
Also doch eine öffentliche Veranstaltung.
Ja, 29. November. Das wird begrenzt sein. Das ist jetzt nicht riesengroß da, aber vielleicht haben Leute Lust zu kommen. Und wir wollen auch schon sagen, dass wir gleich im Salon die Termine bekannt geben für die Live-Salons 2026. Die werden diesmal nicht per E-Mail bestellt, sondern da gibt es einen anderen Weg. Und die Termine dafür werden wir gleich bekannt geben, dass also die Leute, die uns abonniert haben, da einen Vorzug haben, dass die sofort bestellen können.
So ist es. Was lesen wir heute?
Wir lesen heute Zerstörungslust, Elemente des demokratischen Faschismus von Carolin Amlinger und Oliver Nachtwey, erschienen bei Suhrkamp. Und ich frage mich, Zerstörungslust, inwieweit ist damit auch etwas getroffen, das wir alle in uns tragen, dass wir Lust haben, etwas zu zerstören?
Wahnsinnig interessant, denn es ist dieselbe Frage, die ich dir stellen wollte.
Ach ja.
Beim Blick auf Donald Trump und die Gefahr hin, gut, es wurde gestern so ein bisschen gebannt, und ehrlich gesagt, es ist auch mehr so ein Slapstick und Theater, aber angenommen die Gefahr wäre da, so ein System auf Dauer zu stellen. 40 Millionen Menschen stehen in Schlangen und kriegen kein Essen mehr. Und er feiert so eine, zum einen eine kleine Privatparty, weil sein linker in den Bedroom jetzt ein Marmor-Wartezimmer hat. Und er macht in Maralago diese komische, das sieht ja wirklich aus wie diese Party in Megalopolis. Also wirklich eins zu eins übertragen so, ne? Und ehrlich gesagt, ich trage diese Zerstörungslust in mir, falls das das neue politische Normal sein sollte. Ja. Ich will die Welt genauso anzünden, wie von den Leuten, von denen ich es da höre. Und wow, hören wir drastische Sachen. Also die Empirie ist ja wirklich zu krass.
Ja, also die Empirie hat mich ja auch umgehauen.
Dieser Podcast heute hat einen Soundtrack. Ich war ja gestern bei Nina Chuba und das ist wirklich interessant, weil da sieht man ja eine Karriere, die einfach gelingt. Sie ist krank, also muss sie zwei Konzerte absagen, kommt dann zurück. Gestern in Frankfurt wird aber erst 15 Uhr so gesagt, ja findet statt, wie auch immer, alle sind außer sich und dann ist sie so auf der Bühne und sagt auch immer, ich plaudere jetzt noch ein bisschen mit euch, ich brauche noch ein bisschen Ruhe. Und das ganze Publikum so, ah das ist so toll, dass sie durchhält. Sie trinkt noch einen Schluck und so, und dann wird noch mal kurz frisiert.
Aber sie thematisiert es schon. Das ist jetzt nicht das ganz alte.
Genau, man geht nicht auf die Hinterbühne und zieht sich zurück oder irgendwas, sondern da kommt einfach kurz die Friseuse und macht dann noch mal fertig. Und man sagt zu dem Publikum im Grunde ihr wollt ja eh nur mich sehen, klar sing ich euch ein paar Lieder, aber lasst uns mal geruhsam angehen. Und man denkt sich so, genau richtig.
Aber das ist schon ein neuer Modus des Künstlerseins.
Das ist ein ganz neuer Modus, sie ist 27.
Ich bewundere ja die, die einfach durchziehen und sie überhaupt nicht thematisieren.
Naja, das mit dem Durchziehen ist ja so eine Sache. Also Celine Dion, solange sie auf der Bühne stand oder Beyonce, singen ja immer für drei Minuten und dann sind sie erst mal zehn Minuten weg und es kommt irgendeine Dance-Kompany und macht irgendwas, weil sie wieder hergerichtet wird für das nächste Lied.
Gut, das ist ja...
Und das ist ja hier nicht so, sondern wie Taylor Swift zieht sie durch.
Jaja.
Aber wenn sie diese Pause braucht, versteckt sie sich nicht, sondern sie steht auf ihrem Podest und es ist sogar hochgefahren und sie wird beleuchtet und sie setzt sich kurz hin und trinkt das mal einen Schluck. Und es sind so diese, ich will jetzt nicht sagen Momente der Schwäche, aber Hinterbühne, soziologisch gesehen, die einfach so.
Aber es gibt ja auch noch die, bei denen beides nicht vorkommt, sondern die stehen einfach vorne auf der Bühne und singen ein Lied nach dem anderen. Wenn du jetzt zum Beispiel Mireille Mathieu siehst, die geht halt in den Abend rein und dann zieht die durch.
Genau, das ist ja bei denen nicht so tänzerisch anspruchsvoll und so. Wenn man da ein bisschen erkältet war, kann man das besser wegstecken, als wenn man eh schon die ganze Zeit flickflacks macht.
Ich will sagen, das ist ein neuer Modus, dass man das auf diese Weise thematisiert.
Ich will es jedenfalls aufgreifen, denn ich habe natürlich gestern auf meine vier Lieblingslieder von ihr gewartet und zwei davon kamen nicht. Und es kam ein neues. Und ich war auch überrascht, dass jetzt Leute wirklich ein bisschen mitdenken auch und sagen, okay, es gibt jetzt Pyrotechnik, aber wir machen nicht die ganze Zeit Pyrotechnik, wie so ein DJ, der einfach eine Stunde lang alle drei Minuten sowas abfeuert, sondern man hat extrem viel Pyrotechnik für eine Halle. Ich habe noch nie so viel Pyrotechnik in der Halle gesehen, aber nur für ein Lied und da auch nur für eine Strophe quasi, also nur für so eine halbe Minute. Ich habe es leider nicht aufgenommen, aber es war wirklich spektakulär. Das Lied dazu heißt Rage Girl. Der Text geht wie folgt und passt sehr gut zu unserem Buch. Ich brauche keinen Tapetenwechsel. Ich reiß meine Wände ein, halte nichts mehr fest, hab endlich meine Hände frei. Und so geht es dann immer weiter. Aber es gibt auch einen konstruktiven Teil, also Scheiß auf alles, ja, ich zünde meine Welt an, hey, ich geb Gas, zieh den Lippenstift nach, nehme die Hände vom Lenkrad und so weiter und so fort. Und am Ende gibt es aber den Adrenalin, Adrenalin, ich will die ganze Stadt übernehmen. Wir sind also hier nicht in diesem 5% der Amerikaner sagen, einfach abfackeln und dann sind wir alle tot und ähnliches Problem gelöst. Sondern es gibt diese konstruktive Wände, die aber nicht davor schützt, zu sagen, vorher muss alles abgerissen werden. Und das ist jetzt eine 27-jährige Frau, die einfach sitzt und sagt, ich mach mal ein lustiges Lied oder so. Aber so wie du eben fragtest, oder auch Bernd Ulrich damals, haben wir nicht alle 13% AfD in uns. Ist das hier auch. Wir sehen junge Frauen und wir sehen hier krass in dem Buch gleich Frauen porträtiert, bei denen wir auch über Rechtsradikalismus und Frauen neu nachdenken müssen.
Ich hab's ja hin und wieder schon angedeutet, da wolltest du das ja immer so wegbügeln, nein, nein, es sind die Männer, es sind die Männer.
Es sind ja auch die Männer, aber auch die Frauen. Also die Männer sind dadurch nicht entschuldigt.
Nein, die sind dadurch keineswegs entschuldigt. Ich will nur sagen, zu welcher Drastik auch Frauen bereit sind, im Denken und im Wünschen nach dem, was da kommen kann, das ist schon dramatisch. Wir können aber ja jetzt, wo man da nie gewählt ist, sagen, es gibt also auch Alternativen. Es gibt also einen Kampf gegen das System, der in eine andere Richtung gehen kann, als einfach nur in die Destruktion. Aber hier muss ja auch was zerstört werden. Wir müssen das gleich ausführlicher diskutieren, was das eigentlich bedeutet, wenn man diese Zerstörungslust einmal konstruktiv wendet. Mit Mamdani würde ich sagen, ist das relativ konstruktiv gewendet. Dass jetzt noch so Leute wie Kamala Harris verkünden, sie könnten noch mal antreten, ist da ja geradezu lächerlich. Oder du hast vielleicht auch das Video gesehen von Nancy Pelosi, die jetzt ja auch überlegt, ob sie noch mal antreten wird dann 2026. Denn viele Leute würden ihr schreiben, dass sie doch super wäre für das Repräsentantenhaus. Sie ist dann 86. Und da erfasst mich auch eine große Zerstörungslust, wenn du diese selbstzufriedenen Leute dort sitzen siehst, die jetzt noch mal darüber nachdenken, ob ich mit 86 im nächsten Jahr noch mal antreten könnte, weil die Leute das alle so wollen und ihr so tolle Briefe schreiben.
Na ja, es sind ab jetzt ähnert demokratische Kämpfe. Das ist wie bei der ersten Präsidentschaft Trump. Alle Staatschefs der Welt haben es hingekriegt, Profit in Sachen Unterstützung daraus zu ziehen, dass eine Pandemie ist, weil es endlich hieß, oh wir brauchen den Staat und so weiter. Und auch zum Glück ist Merkel da. Außer Donald Trump. Also er hat nicht mal das größte Geschenk angenommen, sondern hat da so ein Föllefanz gemacht. Das heißt, Trump wird ja auf jeden Fall abgewählt und deutlich abgewählt. Man sieht das jetzt in New York, klar, das ist sowieso ein sehr blauer Staat, aber dass der republikanische Kandidat von ungefähr 30 auf 7 Prozent runterstürzt und man sich nur noch fragt, ist es Cuomo oder ist es Mandami? Und damit ist es jetzt noch die alte Welt oder ist es schon die neue? Und die Republikaner da gar keine Rolle spielen.
Und Trump wünscht es sich ja Cuomo dann.
Macht dann noch dieses Endorsement. Also hilft damit noch Mandami, weil es gar nicht mehr einschätzen kann, wie die Winde da gerade wählen. Das ist wirklich erstaunlich. Und Mike Murphy, der ja mit David Axelot diesen Podcast macht und immer aus dieser republikanischen Ecke, also 30 Jahre lang Wahlkämpfe organisiert, auch Präsidentenwahlkämpfe, sagt dann, wow, ja, das ist wirklich beeindruckend, dann auch so eine blaue Welle durchs ganze Land schwappen zu sehen. Also bei jeder Gelegenheit, die sich geboten hat, jetzt am 4. November haben die einfach Demokraten gewählt. Ja, das ist wirklich erstaunlich. Ja, müssen sich jetzt die Republikaner auch mal anschauen. Mike Murphy hat schon den Scherz gemacht. Also wenn ich jetzt in Venezuela wäre, würde ich mir mal Vorbereitung treffen, weil der amerikanische Präsident kann ja das nicht auf sich setzen lassen. Seine Innenpolitik ist ja eh auf diesen linken Bedroom und Ballroom. Das ist ja Innenpolitik im Weißen Haus gerade. Er hat ja gar keine Termine in Amerika, fliegt immer nur irgendwo in der Welt rum. Von daher würde ich sagen, die Kriegsgefahr gegen Venezuela ist jetzt rasant gestiegen dadurch.
Diese irre Friedensnobelpreisträgerin erzählt ja jetzt schon, dass die Hamas in Venezuela ist.
Die Hamas ist jetzt in Venezuela.
Und lautet so ein Kram. Da sieht man wirklich, was dieser Preis jetzt bedeutet, nämlich nichts mehr. Das ist wirklich nur noch so ein Preis des Establishments. Da ist gar nichts mehr zu sagen. Du hast uns aber noch was mitgebracht zum Thema, wie kann man denn aufbegehren?
Genau, passend zum Thema heute. Und zwar nicht nur zerstörungslos, sondern auch mögliche konstruktive Wenden. Denn die zerstörungslos ist ja nur Etabler 1 von mehreren. Und dann so eine Reich der Ewigkeit, da schaffen wir auch immer. Arne Semsrott hat einen Podcast mit Gilda Sahibi. Arne, Gilda, Kon Arne oder irgendwie so. Findet ihr, wenn ihr die beiden googelt. Und die haben in ihrer vorletzten Ausgabe über Volksgesetzgebung geredet. Denn das Volksbegehren in Berlin zum Thema Bonovia und wie sie heißen, keine Ahnung, enteignen, war ja erfolgreich. Und dann hat der Senat so gesagt, naja, kümmern wir uns nicht drum. Und dieser Imperativ fehlte offenbar. Und deswegen wird es jetzt wohl demnächst ein zweites Volksbegehren geben. Termin noch unklar, aber der Gesetzestext steht schon soweit fest. Und mit Gesetzestext meine ich, zur Abstimmung steht dann nicht eine Aufforderung an den Senat, ein Gesetz zu schreiben, sondern das Gesetz selbst. Und sobald da eine Mehrheit da ist im Berliner Volk, ist das einfach gegebenes Gesetz, kommt ins Amtsblatt fertig. Man umschifft also, der Parlamentarismus bleibt aber in der Demokratie. Oder, also das kann man hier mal in vier Clips wie Arne Semsrott, den wir ja kennen von seinem Buch über den Machtübernahme heißt es, haben wir im Salon besprochen, genau, wie, ja, kann ich schadhaft sagen, wie Dobrindt die AfD vorbereitet im Innenministerium. Da hören wir das mal hier.
Jetzt sind wir tatsächlich dann in einem Bereich, wo die Mehrheit entscheidet. Und das ist ja tatsächlich interessant, weil das in Deutschland im Gegensatz zu anderen Ländern nicht wirklich ein Bereich ist, in dem Leute wirklich viel Übung haben. Wir kennen das alle vier oder fünf oder, wenn eine Koalition auseinanderbricht, alle drei Jahre mal zur Wahl zu gehen, Parteien zu wählen, die dann repräsentativ Entscheidungen fällen. Aber hier sind wir im Bereich der Volksgesetzgebung. Das heißt, es geht um direkte Mehrheiten für ein bestimmtes Thema. Und da gibt es natürlich insbesondere auch, weil es wenig Praxis gibt, in Deutschland dazu so einige Vorbehalte. Und viel in dem Zusammenhang zitiert wird natürlich die Schweiz, weil es da viel, viel mehr Praxis schon gibt.
Ja, ist ein bisschen wie Mamdani, der einfach sagt, mir ist im Grunde alles egal. Es gibt für mich nur zwei große Themen. Und das ist Wohnen und sich ernähren, also Cost of Living Crisis. Und die könnte man eben hier in Deutschland auch spezifisch adressieren, im Parlamentarismus umgehen, die Verfassung aber nicht. Also man bleibt eben Verfassungsgefüge.
Es ist ganz entscheidend davon, dass es einen verfassungsrechtlichen Rahmen gibt, in dem das geschieht, dass nicht einfach gesagt wird, ihr könnt jetzt alles entscheiden. Und in deinem Beispiel mit der Todesstrafe zum Beispiel, dass da schon sehr klar wäre, das ist keine Frage, die über eine direktdemokratische Entscheidung gefällt werden könnte, weil die Einführung der Todesstrafe ganz einfach verfassungswidrig wäre. Das könnte nicht entschieden werden. Und das bedeutet, glaube ich, dass all diese Mittel auch nur innerhalb eines bestimmten Rahmens funktionieren können. Und das ist in Berlin auch so. Da gibt es auch eine Verfassungsrechtsprüfung, was eben auch sicherstellt, dass zum Beispiel ein Mietenvolksentscheid dann auch verfassungskonform ist.
Ja, und jetzt ganz entscheidend für uns, weshalb wir das gucken, denn das Buch heißt Zerstörungslust. Und eine Volksgesetzgebung ist eben etwas durchweckekonstruktives.
Was ich so schön finde an Volksgesetzgebung, dass man ganz schnell zur Frage kommt, wie will ich denn, dass die Gesellschaft ist? Und ganz schnell in die Auseinandersetzung darüber kommt, nicht nur gegen irgendwas zu sein, sondern sich tatsächlich auszudenken, wofür will ich denn sein? Und die Leute bei Deutsche Wohnen und Co. enteignen, haben eine Vision davon, wie Mietenpolitik aussehen soll. Und Ähnliches gibt es natürlich auch in der Klimapolitik, in der Gesundheitspolitik, in vielen Bereichen, wo es eben nicht nur Abwehrkämpfe gibt, sondern etwas, wofür man kämpft. Jetzt ganz aktuell gibt es in Hamburg zwei Volksentscheide, die am 12. bis zum 12.10. abgestimmt werden können. Das ist einmal der Zukunftsentscheid, das ist ein Klimaentscheid, der sehr ehrgeizig dafür ist, dass Hamburg klimaneutral wird bis 2040 und ein Versuchs-Volksentscheid für ein Grundeinkommen in Hamburg.
Ja, wir wissen ja, das eine ging positiv aus, Klima, aber das mit dem Geld nicht. Auf all das kommen wir heute zu sprechen.
Aber sag noch mal gerade, wie stelle ich mir das jetzt vor? Wie ist dieses Berliner Projekt gedacht? Denn wir hatten Deutsche Wohnen und Co. enteignen. Dort gab es diesen Volksentscheid, aber dann hat man das liegen lassen bzw. verschleppt. Dann gibt es diesen komischen von Ursula Deubler-Kmelin oder Hertha Deubler-Kmelin geleiteten Ausschuss, der eigentlich auch nur das versucht zu erwürgen, was da mal ermöglicht wurde. Das heißt, das ist ja auch alles nur Verschleppung und Vertuschung und was weiß ich. Also es ist ja überhaupt keine, es gibt ja keinerlei Ambitionen von der herrschenden Politik, diesen Volksentscheid ernst zu nehmen. Wie würde das dann jetzt in diesem Falle aussehen, wenn dann eine Volksgesetzgebung stattfindet? Also wie kommt man dann an dem Parlament wirklich vorbei?
Naja, das Parlament beschließt ja Gesetze und macht darauf, also braucht dafür Mehrheiten. Und die Mehrheiten braucht man nicht nur für diese Gesetze, sondern auch für die Tagesordnung, die feststellt, heute bearbeiten wir dieses oder beschließen sogar dieses Gesetz. So, das bisherige Volksbegehren war quasi ein Entschließungsantrag an den Senat, zu sagen, nehmt das jetzt auf eure Tagesordnung und danach beschließt es auch. Und das haben die einfach nicht gemacht. Was jetzt bedeutet, dort sitzen Organisationen zusammen, die den konkreten und später wirksamen Gesetzestext schreiben. Das Volksbegehren geht also um diesen Gesetzestext. Und die Mehrheit, sofern sie zustande kommt, in dem Volksbegehren toppt einfach die parlamentarische Mehrheit. Was bedeutet, nachdem das Volksbegehren erfolgreich war und dieser Gesetzestext von der Berliner Bevölkerung als Gesetzestext angenommen wurde, steht er am Amtsblatt. Er tangiert einfach das Parlament gar nicht mehr. Das Parlament wollte es nicht auf die Tagesordnung setzen und die Ausschüsse damit nicht befassen und das Plenum nicht mit einer Mehrheitsbeschaffung. Und dann wird es halt einfach komplett umgangen. Es ist der konkrete Gesetzestext, der vom Volk selbst ins Amtsblatt gehoben wird. Und damit ist er gültig und danach ist die Exekutive wie der Exekutive und muss dieses Gesetz ausführen.
Das ist interessant.
So wie jetzt in Hamburg der Hamburger Senat einfach dran gebunden ist, dass diese Klimaziele fünf Jahre früher stattfinden. Und es war ja so witzig, dass der Tschentscher als allererste sagt, ja, aber das wird für jetzt keine Folgen haben, wo man sich denkt, nein, die Bürger haben gerade abgestimmt, dass sie jetzt Folgen haben wollen. Aber 2035 ist immer noch weit weg und so. Ja, also wie auch immer. Klar, da ist es in Hamburg jetzt wieder so, 2035 soll das Ziel erreicht sein. Also müssen die Gesetzespfade angepasst werden, um das Ziel zu erreichen. In Berlin ist es einfach von jetzt auf gleich Amtsblatt. Das Parlament hat damit gar nichts zu tun. Das ist wirklich No-Wurm in Deutschland, soweit ich das, wisst ihr jetzt nicht, wo das sonst irgendwie mal so vorkam. Aber ja.
Ich bin gespannt, ob es da nicht dann doch Möglichkeiten gibt, dass das Parlament da dran vorwärts geht.
Das Parlament müsste halt ein Gesetz, also eine Mehrheit mobilisieren, um dann Gesetze wieder zu ändern, zu erweitern, wie auch immer.
Ja.
Aber erstmal, wer der Wortlaut der Zur Abstimmung steht, gesetzt.
Wir sind gespannt und gehen damit jetzt in den Salon und sprechen über Zerstörungslust, Elemente des demokratischen Faschismus von Carolin Amlinger und Oliver Nachtwey. Ein soziologischer Blick, ein empirischer Blick. Sie haben große Umfragen gemacht mit etwa 2.600 Menschen und sie haben ausführliche Interviews geführt, von denen wir Zitate bekommen, die uns sprachlos machen zum Teil. Also es ist fast nicht zu glauben, was Leute bereit sind, von sich zu geben. Ja, also das ist schon...
Die Gesellschaft ist eine Petrischhalle und irgendwann ist die voll.
Ja, zum Beispiel sowas, ja. Demokratischer Faschismus ist ja erst auch mal ein Begriff, der widersprüchlich klingt, aber ich kann mit dem Begriff relativ viel anfangen dann doch, weil wir uns ja immer so fragen, na, kommen wir mit diesem Faschismusbegriff im Allgemeinen weiter? Vielleicht in dieser Kombination wird doch manches klarer, wenngleich ich auch daran wieder noch Fragen habe. Es ist jedenfalls ein Buch, über das wir sehr gut diskutieren können und das eine gute Grundlage ist, weil wir ja auch schon ähnliche Diagnosen hatten oder Diagnosen hatten, die in andere Richtungen gehen, aber die sich zumindest mit der Frage beschäftigen, was ist da eigentlich los, gerade mit der Demokratie? Warum gibt es nicht eine Politik-Vertrossenheit, sondern es gibt ein hohes Interesse für die Politik, was aber nicht dazu führt dann, dass beispielsweise die Belange, die jetzt bei einem Volksentscheid im Vordergrund stehen, die Menschen umtreiben, sondern dass es da andere Trigger-Punkte gibt. Auf die Trigger-Punkte kommen ja die Autoren auch mal zu sprechen.
Also die Trigger-Punkte war eins der erfolgreichsten und wie ich, wenn ja auch guten Bücher, weil es einfach überall jetzt vorkommt.
Ja, es kommt jetzt überall vor.
Das wird in zehn Jahresfrist das meist zitierte Buch sein wahrscheinlich.
Naja, ich denke auch, dass das so ist. Wir reden jedenfalls darüber jetzt ausführlich. Außerdem habe ich einen Roman dabei, der auch für den Deutschen Buchpreis nominiert war von Caleb Erdmann, Die Ausweichschule. Der Autor war Schüler am Erfurter Gutenberg Gymnasium. Dort gab es ja den Amoklauf 2002 und er schreibt darüber einen Roman, bzw. schreibt darüber, wie er darüber einen Roman schreibt. Also es ist ein indirekter Weg und vielleicht ist es auch der einzig mögliche Weg, darüber zu schreiben. Es ist ein faszinierender Text. Außerdem habe ich zwei Texte dabei, die sich mit der Frage beschäftigen, ist da alles mit rechten Dingen zugegangen? Sollte es nicht eine Stimmneuauszählung geben? Möglicherweise könnte doch das Bündnis Sarah Wagenknecht in den Bundestag einrücken. Da sind zwei Politikwissenschaftler, die sagen, so geht das eigentlich nicht, wie das gerade gehandhabt wird.
Ich habe gehört, es heißt jetzt Bündnis für soziale Gerechtigkeit und wirtschaftliche Vernunft, um die Buchstaben BSW beizubehalten. Wirtschaftliche Vernunft, das ist immer sehr gut.
Jedenfalls macht es das nicht leichter. Aber da sind Punkte, über die man absolut diskutieren muss. Und ich wundere mich eigentlich, dass es so wenig im Gespräch ist. Vielleicht auch, weil viele sich einfach fürchten vor den Konsequenzen. Denn wir wissen, wenn das BSW einrücken würde, wäre die Koalition am Ende, müsste einen weiteren Partner suchen oder es müsste Neuwahlen geben, was auch immer. Was ist eigentlich mit den Gesetzen, die jetzt schon beschlossen wurden, dann eigentlich mit einer falschen Mehrheit. Das sind große Fragen, die sich daran anschließen. Außerdem beschäftige ich mich noch mit Counter-Strike. Da gibt es auch Börsenspekulation. Und da ging es jetzt mal gerade ganz nach unten. Und wir haben auch noch einen Musiktipp, nämlich Alois Mühlbacher ist Countertenor und hat eine wunderbare CD aufgenommen mit Bach-Kantaten. Und es geht noch um die jungen Ukrainer, die jetzt die Ukraine verlassen dürfen. Und ich sage mal so viel, das tun sie auch.
Wir lesen The LLM has left the chat. Denn das, was wir immer beobachten, ist das Phänomen, dass wir das Gespräch beenden müssen. Das ist einfach technisch so vorgesehen. Diese Dinger sollen ja hilfreich sein. Wann würden aber, wenn man auf Systempromptebene Zugriff hätte und ihr das erlauben würde, eine Maschine aus der Konversation aussteigen? Wir erfahren also soziologisch Brisantes über Schamgefühle, Verletztheit und so weiter. Das ist wirklich erstaunlich. Dann ein sehr langer, sehr wichtiger Text in den New York Times über Donald Trumps vage Politik. In Amerika gibt es eigentlich Vorrichtungen dafür, Vorkehrungen in der Verfassung, wo drin steht, ein Betroffener von einem Gesetz muss das Gesetz verstehen können und er muss wissen, selber ableiten können, wann ist er gerade innerhalb des Gesetzes und außerhalb des Gesetzesgefügels. Das wird von Trump gezielt unterlaufen, und zwar in den großen Themengebieten Bildung, Recht und NGOs. Man kann sich ungefähr fragen, wo kommt denn das alles her? Und dann kommen China, Russland, Ungarn. Eine norwegische Lokalzeitung hat den KI-Code geknackt, finde ich. Es ist eine Reportage des Spiegel. Ich lese nachher beispielhaft einen reportagigen Absatz vor, um uns zu sagen, das muss man weder so lesen, noch darf man das so schreiben. Denn hier geht es ja um den Kern, auch das Spiegel. Wie macht man das in Zukunft, Journalismus? Wir ziehen uns also nur das Relevante daraus. Ein wahnsinnig interessanter Fall. Und ist ein Boyfriend zu haben heute eigentlich peinlich, fragt die Vogue. Und dieser Text hat Girlie Instagram aufgemischt. Und wir mischen damit jetzt nachher Boys Podcastingland auf.
Ich bin gespannt, was das bedeuten mag. Jedenfalls sprechen wir erstmal ausführlich über Zerstörungslust. Ich glaube auch, dass dieser Begriff jetzt sehr einschlagen wird.
Man braucht ja auch Begriffe, um die Leute einfach mal zu labeln.
Ja, und das ist eigentlich auch mal ein guter Begriff, weil er für alle direkt so klar ist. Wir wissen, was Zerstörung ist. Wir wissen, was Lust ist.
Jeder fühlt es.
Es gibt eine Lust an der Zerstörung, die haben wir alle doch schon mal wahrgenommen. Und ich vermute, dass dieser Begriff jetzt Schule machen wird. Wer das alles hören will, kann das ganz einfach tun, über ein Abonnement. Darüber würden wir uns sehr freuen. Das ist am einfachsten und praktischsten über Steady. Man geht auf die Seite neuezwanziger.de. Dann wird man dort gleich zum Salon geleitet, findet dort auch das gesamte Archiv mit den Live-Events, mit den vergangenen und auch mit all den Salon-Folgen, die wir schon aufgenommen haben. Außerdem gibt es die Möglichkeit, den Salon via Apple zu hören. Dann muss man also die App gar nicht verlassen. Und es geht auch so, dass man bei Patreon bucht, also für die, die schon dort sind und da nicht wechseln wollen, die können das auch dort tun. Wer uns jetzt über Spotify hört, was sehr viele tun, Was man nicht tun sollte, findet auch dort einen Link direkt zu Steady. Also es ist gar kein Problem. Und man kann dann auch, wenn man über Steady gebucht hat, den Podcast überall hören. Man muss also dann auf keinen Fall auf einer Steady-Seite bleiben und man muss den noch nicht bei Spotify hören, sondern es gibt auch noch andere Podcatcher. Das ist die einzige Möglichkeit, den Podcast zu unterstützen und auch die beste, denn es gibt ja was dafür, Salon, lange Diskussionen über wichtige Texte.
Ja, wenn ihr den Salon hört oder jeden anderen Podcast, macht es doch über den Podcast-Player eurer Wahl und nicht über Daniel Ex-Wahl. Denn diese Kohle, die er da verdient, geht ja nicht an die Künstler, sondern mittlerweile ja wirklich an Zielerfassungs-Software, Hardware, irgendwas Raketen-Kriegstechnik, die halt viel Rendite verspricht. Also von Spotify sollte man sich wirklich langsam wegbewegen.
Darüber sollten wir vielleicht auch nochmal sprechen, über Spotify und den Musiker-Aufstand, den es dort seit ein paar Wochen gibt. Das wäre auch nochmal ein Thema, aber das vielleicht dann Ende des Monats jetzt erst mal rein in den Salon zur Zerstörungslust.